When I was a child walking along
the beaches I saw so many fish
along the beach
[Music]
My name is Juan Gastro Montaño I am 71
years old and I have lived here
in Cabo
Pulmo fishing has been  important because it is the
livelihood for this community
from the age of 12 I fished
learning
from 15 onwards I was already a
slow professional fisherman but commercial fishing started
[Music]
we noticed that there was a
massive catch of fish
and that  It was the worst thing we did,
it was visibly noticing that the
fish were scarce, it was no longer very
profitable to fish in this place,
here it was no longer enough to live
[Music]
we stopped fishing like this from one day
to the next
and we seeing how difficult it was  there
was fishing, because the generation of
us, my brothers and I, were the ones who
immediately said that if we have to
change this because fishing
is very difficult, we invest a lot and it
takes us out  We practically nothing
today we work on ecotourism it
was very, very difficult but
we did it
and it's a way to conserve the reef
and be able to dedicate ourselves to something else
[Music]
they were getting a taste of moving
tourists because there they received the payment
that they collected and spent  They
were at home early in the morning with little gasoline and that was what
prompted them to
stop lending
[Music]
we all have benefits from this reef that has
already recovered 500% not one hundred percent
[Music]
and there is me that my father and my grandfather
Seeing it right now as it is and the reef recovered,
everyone would think like when
they were children they would say return,
return the wealth we had
when love
and I think that
they will be very proud
[Music
] other generations see it when
we no longer  We are here,
we are like sentinels who
watch over this and take care of it.
I tell the children that I hope that one
of you remains engraved in their minds
and hearts.
something of what I am saying so that
there are no books that talk about this at
least you will say it when I already
our
[Music]